hi my name is Richard Branson and my
favorite movie is man on wire I was born
never to say no I mean life and life's
been a lot more fun saying yes I think
the people in life who you know say yes
to everything generally speaking you
know they may live a short life or they
live a very full life and you know that
life is definitely the richer for it I
suppose I related particularly - you
know what Philippe was trying to do
you're risking your your life to try to
accomplish something that nobody's
accomplished before the leap was an
incredible Frenchman who as a young man
used to juggle and perform on the
streets and he learned to cross a rope
on the streets and make a little bit of
extra money by doing so man and wah
followed his exploits to see whether he
could quietly put a rope across the Twin
Towers and cross it without anybody
finding out that he was doing it and not
getting caught was remarkable the great
thing about this documentary was it was
full of raw footage it followed him
behind the scenes and you really felt
that that you were participating this
was the real the real person doing the
real thing it was great that you know
people then tried to turn it into a
feature film the walk it was beautifully
directed
it's fascinating when you know that
you're still watching a film where you
you know you're terrified that they're
going to fall
everybody watching will have experienced
all the emotions you know he was at the
pinnacle of his life up there it was
going to be difficult for him ever to
surmount him a mountain that was going
to be greater than this particular
project and he didn't want to come down
off that Wow
literally there was one moment where he
he lays down on the wire and you can
sort of feel you know damn it
you know I've got this far I'm gonna
milk it for all have hope it's all it's
got I want to enjoy every second of it
and I don't blame him for it
my name is Philippe Petit I'm a wire
Walker you just have to be careful not
to get too comfortable in life and get
into that mold where you want to sort of
sit in a comfortable armchair and watch
other people do you do these things it's
so much more fun to be doing them
yourself I understand exactly where
Phillips Phillips coming from and I'm
being very fortunate be able to follow
in his footsteps I've been able in my
life to somehow make these challenges a
reality I love movies that's a wrap
[Music]
[Music]
you